quand on donne tout et qu'on est
récompensé c'est fabuleux un point
faible à
on
j'ai misé sur lui pour futur très proche
c'est pas uniquement pour ses qualités
de valeur c'est justement parce que
c'est tellement rare garçon qui a été
élevé à la dure avec des parrains qui
avait une mentalité exceptionnelle
[Musique]
vas-y d'habitat en face à on se retrouve
tout l'après midi en train de jouer au
foot sur le carrelage après l'école et
on passait des journées chez un traiteur
de frapper dans le ballon
[Musique]
nous
il fallait ressortir deux qualités je
pense se seraient ils ont attaqué la
discrétion surtout pas ces deux qualités
primordiales qu'il a
[Musique]
c'est magnifique m'était jamais arrivé
marquer deux buts un seul match
catégorique son cadet minime espoir donc
deux buts ses mots
[Musique]
ses démons en se disant qu'on était
champion du moindre qu'en qu'il fallait
quoi qu'on réalise quoi que c'était
c'était la plus belle chose
le footballeur quoi
[Musique]
je peux pas vous dire que je suis fier
de ce geste mais en même temps je le
regarde pas parce que si je le
regrettais ça voudrait dire que je donne
raison à ses atouts ses mots que cette
personne m'a dit et ça je peux plus je
peux pas je peux pas l'accepter
[Musique]
m
non mais la décision de nos séries de
proximania ce que ce moment bordeaux le
croquer ce moment important à ce moment
de la vie à kasséré sont pas là par
hasard
[Musique]